salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor
alors aujourd'hui on est au château
Lancia dans le Haut Languedoc donc c'est
un des plus gros château du coin vous
allez voir pourquoi on est ici c'est
pour chercher des trésors tout d'abord
dans leur mare
[Musique]
nous voilà donc à la première mare du
château donc plutôt sympa je pense qu'on
va jeter les aimants il y a peut-être
des petits trésors là-dedans et en
parlant de trésor il y en a un deuxième
qui se cache peut-être dans ma main
enfin le trésor si on réussit à résoudre
les énigmes puisqu'en effet on est en
partenariat avec l'élixir d'or qui nous
a offert ce parchemin
et qui a caché un trésor d'une valeur de
100000 euros quelque part en France donc
100000 euros pas en cash mais en
bouteille de vin pourquoi en bouteille
de vin là ça y est vous comprenez
pourquoi on est ici cette chasse au
trésor a été créée en partenariat avec
43 domaine viticole dans toute la France
je vais pas spoil les énigmes alors vous
avez un parchemin avec 6 énigmes et
l'objectif est de déchiffrer ses énigmes
c'est une chasse au trésor la chasse au
trésor se déroule à distance donc vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous déplacer vous
n'avez pas besoin non plus d'avoir de
matériel spécifique tels que des aimants
ou des détecteurs vous pouvez faire
votre chasse au trésor depuis la maison
en résolvant ses énigmes là voici la
cave à gagner et sa composition et vous
avez ici le château de l'ancien qui nous
accueille aujourd'hui pour pêcher à
l'aimant grand merci à eux merci à eux
si vous voulez participer à cette chasse
au trésor le droit d'entrée c'est ce
parchemin que vous retrouverez sur le
site vous avez le code promo pêcheur de
trésor 10 qui vous offre 10% sur toute
la boule
10% sur l'achat du parchemin et il
existe aussi une forme dématérialisée en
ebook maintenant je vais vous laisser en
compagnie de Chloé qui va vous parler du
château
de communication et de notoriasme au
domaine et le château Lancia donc ça
domaine viticole de 80 hectares en pic
Saint-Loup géré par la famille Valentin
Durand et ici on produit une dizaine de
cuvées en bio et HVE
apporté des bouteilles c'est ça tout à
fait donc nous vous pouvez retrouver
dans la cave Finale 4 cuvées à nous des
cuvées qui peuvent se garder puisqu'on
ne sait pas quand est-ce que ça va
trouver la cas finale donc on est sur
des cuvées blanc et rouge qui peuvent se
garder 10 15 voire 20 ans et que pour le
gagnant on pourra déguster quand il le
trouvera ou encore dans quelques années
j'ai regardé toutes les règles du
concours vous allez jusqu'à 2028 pour
trouver l'énigme
et la cave est actuellement exposée au
château de Vaux-le-Vicomte où toutes les
bouteilles sont réunies donc vous pouvez
aller les voir dès maintenant vous avez
toutes les infos sur le site il est très
bien fait n'hésitez pas à les jeter un
œil maintenant allez c'est parti rasta
tu es prêt
ça fait très longtemps qu'on l'a pas
exploré
pas fait une blague et cacher le trésor
ici ah ça serait drôle hein sans faire
les énigmes comment il s'appelle ce
lacne le lac des figuiers et il s'agit
maintenant du nom
travaille un petit peu on a refait
l'étiquette et le nom et on voulait
parler de lac parce qu'on a quand même
plusieurs lacs sur le domaine si on
trouve rien est-ce qu'on peut repartir
avec une bouteille de rosée
[Rires]
vous êtes prêt pour le premier lancer le
plus important
je vais essayer de tirer quand même
par-dessus le l'arbre c'est pas grave
si on trouve des ouais rien du vieux
matériel agricole ça peut être sympa
en tout cas le cadre est très beau là
vous pouvez apercevoir le Pic Saint-Loup
là-haut
j'ai l'impression qu'on a pas grand
chose
pour l'instant
je vais voir là-bas
au moins une trouvaille tu parles pas de
toi
parce que là tu vois ça me
en train de penser
qu'est-ce que c'est toi tu es l'expert
ise
un peu mieux
non comme ça
[Musique]
tu peux y aller sans mouiller ton short
c'est pas profond au moins il y a
quelque chose déjà dans une barre comme
ça c'était pas gagné
en vrai il vient de pleuvoir donc l'eau
n'est pas trop chaude et puis
rassure-toi comme tu peux
un vieux piqué c'est pas jeune ça non
mais voilà au moins c'est déjà sympa je
vais continuer à lancer mais c'est bien
c'est bizarre qu'il soit pas venu voilà
le trésor tient
peut-être que ils avaient une petite
barre qu'ils attaché une barque
premier trésor ouais
après vous inquiétez pas on a des idées
en tête pour aller pêcher à d'autres
endroits pas loin qui ont l'air très
prometteurs aussi ah on va aller au
canal le plus proche du domaine donc
vous verrez bien l'adresse et le site du
domaine seront eux aussi en description
de la vidéo si vous voulez du vin ouais
parce que pour pêcher les mains dans le
lac on conseille pas ouais pas besoin à
éviter bon ben le lac du domaine est
propre voilà ce qu'on a pêché donc
du coup on a gagné une bouteille là
alors là ça commence très bien quand tu
as perdu son aimant dans l'eau dès son
premier lancer il a oublié de l'attacher
à un point fixe deuxième lancer
et il commence à pleuvoir
non on va l'attacher un point fixe comme
on fait toujours t'inquiète
encore
Portugal je crois et oui Quentin dit
encore les pays même quand c'est les
pièces en euros pas marrant
et du coup à chaque fois je crois que
c'est des pièces intéressantes c'est des
centimes il a repéré avec la corde et
pas avec les mains oh les mains c'est
trop loin
bon ben écoute c'est bien c'est un bon
début on a trouvé un aimant deux pièces
l'une sur l'autre et du coup ils en ont
ce côté ouais l'autre côté il est
détruit
pour moi c'est pas normal qui est autant
de pièces ici parce que c'est pas un
endroit où tu fais des vœux
allez on continue alors hop le lancer
magnifique de Quentin
je crois que j'ai un sachet ou une
barquette
oh c'est quoi ce bordel
oui mais c'est quoi c'est comment
5 centimes encore mais garde-les en vrai
ça en fait beaucoup là tu les as mis où
les tiens
ah ah ah qu'est-ce que c'est
non
je vous ai fait le fameux Nice parce que
ça j'aime bien est-ce que c'est un
laïole bon il a pris cher il manque le
bois et tout ça mais moi ça doit être un
laïole oui c'est un Laguiole voilà bah
faudra trouver du bois de rechange
voiture je crois mais une sorte de
résistance Mitsubishi
c'est ouais je sais pas
ouais ouais ça vient Quentin j'ai pris
mon pote
j'aime bien le poids j'aime bien le
poids
voyons voir ce que ce canal nous a
offert
[Musique]
c'est intéressant ça
c'est un truc de ouf là
oh purée
c'est rempli d'argent vous voyez on a
trouvé notre propre trésor c'est
incroyable on est ici depuis 5 minutes
on vous a parlé de trésor tout à l'heure
on trace tout droit on vient voir un
spot et on trouve un trésor mais c'est
dingue oh j'adore magnifique ok les gars
c'est vraiment pour ce genre de
découverte qu'on fait ça et c'est
vraiment c'est découvert là qu'on adore
partager avec vous maintenant je pense
d'abord on va placer
un et deux euros quand même
il est rempli rempli rempli de pièces
la quantité
la quantité qui doit avoir on continue
d'ouvrir à la maison pour pas en mettre
partout à la maison on vous met la suite
de l'ouverture à la maison
voilà du coup ça a bien mordu
c'est oh il y en a encore d'autres
choses c'est peut-être pas de baluchon
moi je dis parce que j'en ai senti je me
suis promené quand j'ai tiré à côté
Quentin je suis persuadé qu'il y en a
d'autres des baluchons remplis de pièces
et ils sont juste en face OK
ah bah si ça c'est ça surtout que tu es
attaché ouais vous êtes de plus en plus
à nous regarder et depuis un peu partout
dans le monde donc ça ça nous fait très
plaisir spécial dédicace aujourd'hui à
tous ceux qui sont en Nouvelle-Calédonie
ou à Mayotte
cet aimant là c'est pour vous
enfin le lancer
allez on va voir ce qu'on a trouvé ah ça
ça vient d'un outil non c'est quoi
c'est possible mais en plus
un moteur
de quoi ça
c'est pas un truc de tondeuse ou quoi
non arrête
n'hésitez pas à nous dire plus d'info en
commentaire en tout cas bien joué
d'avoir ramené ça jusqu'au bout et pour
le coup effectivement il est pas jeune
c'est juste qu'il a été loupé par les
autres pêcheurs allemands
mais c'est pas mal
dommage c'est quoi une sorte de
un crochet
quand tu renvoies ta corde dans l'eau
comme tout à l'heure
tu en penses quoi
il reste des choses mais la plupart sont
récentes ou bien dans la vase ou des
fois en changeant un peu les arbres on
ne réalise à voir donc l'avantage c'est
un canal il y a des choses intéressantes
donc dans tous les cas dès qu'on a
quelque chose on est content
bon je me suis moqué de Quentin j'ai
jeté mon aimant moi aussi dans l'eau
avec toute la corde alors pour ma
défense moi je l'avais attaché là dessus
il y a quelque chose là
dans les herbes
bon je me suis décalé entre les deux
ponts j'ai rempli celui-là et il y aura
plus de choses je pense que ce sera
moins fait
désolé pour le bruit des voitures
appellera
sur le pont
là j'ai eu quelque chose sous le pont
qui est assez lourd ah je coincé ah pour
le treuil pour changer d'endroit
[Musique]
ouf
oh c'est lourd
c'est une mobylette c'est peugeot 103 je
crois ça fait un moment qu'elle est là
celle-là merci
il y a encore la béquille et il y a une
elle part en Lambo
[Musique]
allez on va voir ce qu'on arrive à
attraper
de
pas que ça vient à 47 ça je vais
continuer alors
on va voir ce que c'est ensemble
j'adore
il est super beau c'est une fin elle est
super belle c'est une masse
et le manche est en bois franchement
c'est superbe j'ai quelque chose je suis
obligé de descendre
ah c'est un ah ben je pense que c'est le
phare le tour de phare de ma moto
[Musique]
oh là là c'est de la voiture tout ça
allez
sois gentil arrête de faire le toboggan
yes je l'ai je l'ai je l'ai je l'ai et
ça les gars gros morceau de plastique
elle a regardé les gars une pince je me
suis mis de l'autre côté du pont en face
de Baptiste je pense qu'on va trouver
avec notre aimant et c'est l'inverse de
la qualité en plus
ah oui elle s'ouvre
un peu de WD40 là parce que
elle est assez dur mais elle devrait
fonctionner
OK
une chaîne une chaîne une chaîne
mais malheureusement en acier
c'est la Baptiste elle vole
là il y a un problème là
[Musique]
je vais le rejoindre où je vais pas le
rejoindre
allez j'arrive ok j'ai réussi à
rejoindre Quentin de l'autre côté et
voyez les traces des mains il a réussi
quand même à le faire traîner jusque là
mais pas le décrocher il faut savoir que
c'est le Barbarian 1600 kg de chez
Maison de la détection et ça quand c'est
vraiment sur de la fonte pure faut y
aller là ça fait quelques semaines enfin
quelques mois qu'on a repris la muscu
on va essayer on va retourner la
casquette franchement si tu arrives seul
gros respect déjà il faut que tu fasses
un angle de côté je pense tu tires par
exemple genre comme ça un coup sec mais
vraiment faut y aller tout donner vous
êtes prêts
vous êtes prêts
le barbare ça fait le taf sinon on
conseille quand même le terror pour
commencer doucement ouais ben c'est
surtout parce que là ça va c'est hors de
l'eau mais si c'est pareil au fond de
l'eau va tirer quoi on annoncera le
résultat sur notre Instagram qui est en
description de la vidéo et qui s'affiche
ici
ça va être plus compliqué que prévu de
compter je pense
les clés
on va être sûr qu'il y a rien
le trésor on espère que vous avez
apprécié les découvertes moi j'ai
vraiment adoré trouver ce baluchon même
s'il était pas rempli de C il était
quand même bien rempli et
on va revenir il y a encore pas mal de
distance à faire n'hésitez pas donc à
aller sur les liens en description pour
le parchemin et pour trouver le trésor
avec les bouteilles de vin et vous
abonner et à vous abonner nous je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on va rentrer on va
doucher tout et puis on va commencer à
attaquer la première énigme